so macht man das perfekte Steak und
unsere Geheimzutat heißt Knoblauchpulver
glaub mir das ändert alles habe ich von
Google foods dem Steak König auf Youtube
legen wir los wir nehmen ein Steak gehen
mit ordentlich Salz dran Knoblauchpulver
nicht spannend und frischem Pfeffer das
wiederholen wir von allen Seiten
inklusive der Ränder und dann ist unser
Steak schon bereit für die Pfanne
Kontakt schaffen und bei maximaler Hitze
12 Minuten wenn ihr riechen könntet was
ich rieche so muss ein Steak Aussehen
jetzt sind noch die Seiten dran dann
geben wir unser Deck in die indirekte
Hitze für 1 2 Minuten pro Seite ungefähr
4 Minuten später ich nehme mein Steak
vom Grill und Deck es ab für ungefähr 5
Minuten unser Steak hat fertig geruht
und es sieht wunderschön aus und wir
schneiden einmal an fühlt sich gut an
und es sieht auch gut aus seht ihr den
Garpunkt für mich das perfekt ist Steak
das Knoblauchpulver boostet den Steak
Geschmack das umami dieses fleischige
wird einfach vollends auseinander
genommen
das hier ist ein Steak wie es sein
sollte